rocky has been showing us ways we can
celebrate valentine's day around town
yesterday
she was in the twilight zone and today
she is in venice italy
hey rocky hey mercedes yes i am in the
city of love right marcelo yes this is
my valentine's date for the day of our
cello here and tell us where we're at
right now on the gondolas of the
venetian we are in the beautiful
venetian hotel resort as you can see
around
it's been voted as one of the top
romantic hotels in the world as we glide
under the bridges
under this beautiful sky i see you had
to bend down pretty low there i would
have
i understand yes i have been lucky not
to hit my head yes
right right right okay so let's talk
about the history behind the gondola
rise and why this is significant well
venice of course is known as the city of
love and
people couples have been riding the
gondolas for hundreds of years
and as you look around here this is why
the city does look like this the
venetian hotel
recreated it for you right here on the
las vegas boulevard
beautiful and do you have any um ideas
or any
memories from couples that are riding
with you oh yes what
is valentine's week right yes it is and
one of my favorites was i had
two 98 year olds and they were
celebrating their 80-year anniversary
and i asked the man what is your secret
of happiness and they said we share
memories together and laugh together and
what other great thing to do for
valentine's day
wow marcelo that was a beautiful story
and perfect to get us into the spirit
you guys have to come down
if either even if you're a local you
know this is such a great
idea because i've been here for a while
i've been coming here my entire life and
i've never
ridden the gondola and now i can say
that i did yeah you can walk along here
all day it's a completely different
experience inside the gondola so how can
people ride
you we open every day at 10 a.m and you
can make a reservation
or just walk in and get your tickets
beautiful can we personally request
marcelo you can
i'd love to take you down the beautiful
canal gorgeous okay and the 4 pm we're
gonna talk specialty valentine's drinks
here at the venetians i'll send it back
to you
oh he is adorable i love him thank you
rocky we will check
back in with you during that 4pm
newscast